in august of 87
we had 11 stores and 100 employees
and a dream to create a national retail
company
around the coffee experience good coffee
in america
but there was another dream i had and
that was to build a different
type of company a company that
potentially could achieve
the delicate balance between
profitability
and the fiscal responsibility of
building shareholder value
but the balance of also having a heart
benevolence
and integrating a social conscience in
everything the company would do
and hopefully one day remember this was
87
the company would be known as much for
its
values its culture its guiding
principles
as it would the quality of its coffee
fast forward from 87 to 89 and 80 in
1990 the company was
beginning to get some traction we had
about 50 stores
we still were not making money and i
think we all realized at the time that
we were not
in the coffee business serving people
but we were in the people business
serving coffee
that if we wanted to exceed the
expectations of the customer
we had to first exceed the expectations
of our people
we made a very important strategic
decision early on
that franchising could not maintain the
culture and values of the company
that all it would be would be an access
to cheap capital
and so we continued on track of opening
and building a company-owned system